- We're back with the stars and director
of the new Netflix movie "The
School for Good and Evil".
Sofia Wylie, Sophia Anne
Caruso, Charlize Theron,
Kerry Washington, Paul Feig.
It's a lot of people there, I love it.
And we also have an audience
full of good and evil characters.
(audience cheers)
So, Paul, nice to see you again.
- Good to see you again. -
[Kelly] This time, in person.
- I know, exactly. Not over Zoom.
- [Kelly] Yes, you look...
- And last time I talked
to you I was in Belfast
- [Kelly] Great over zoom.
- shooting this movie.
- I know, I know.
And you looked fabulous then.
- Thanks.
- You look fabulous now.
- Why, thank you.
- So you directed movies
with strong female casts,
like "Bridesmaids," "Ghostbusters."
(audience cheers)
I mean, now this one.
So, I assume that's not a coincidence.
Did you have like, strong female,
like, empowering people
in your life growing up?
- Yeah, I mean most of my
friends growing up were girls,
and women, as I grew up.
And I was an only child,
really close to my mom.
And I just got tired of watching movies
where women had one
dimensional characters,
especially comedies.
- We were too.
- [Paul] Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Well, especially when I got to Hollywood
and I became friends
with so many, you know,
comedic actresses and
just, you know, actors.
And they were so great.
I'd see them in a movie and
they were playing, you know,
the shrewish girlfriend
or the terrible wife,
and not getting to be funny
and not getting to have a good role.
And I was just like, I hate this.
And I love telling women's
stories anyways, so it's just,
there's nothing else I
wanna do in my career.
- Well, you're killing it.
- [Paul] Oh, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Look at who I get to work
with though, you know.
- [Kelly] It's an amazing cast.
- Yeah.
- Job well done casting, whoever did that.
How was it working with Paul?
You said you'd worked with
Paul before, obviously,
so you'd worked with him before.
But how is it working with him,
different than maybe other directors?
- He's effortlessly collaborative.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.
- Yeah, I sometimes as an actor,
I feel like I'm putting everybody out.
- [Paul] (chuckles) Certainly not.
- Like, oh, what about
this, what about this?
What if we don't do this?
What if...
And Paul never makes you feel that way.
Paul's excited by ideas, and
it's exhausting sometimes.
I don't know how he does it,
'cause actors can be a lot.
So, it's really nice
when there's a sincerity
behind the collaborative nature
that he brings to the set.
- But I love it, I mean,
that's the only way I can work with women,
you know, I'm not like, you know,
like, I have some great
insight into women's stories
and how, you know, how everybody thinks,
but I collaborate, you know.
That's like how, you know,
here's what I want you to do.
And they're like, "I don't
know if it would be like that."
Oh, cool, how is it?
So then we're a constant collaboration
and that's how it should always be.
It should be men and
women working together.
So we both avoid stereotyping
each other, both ways.
- We just found out how
you've been married so long.
(audience claps)
- And he's funny, which is always a plus.
He's so funny.
He's just a natural ability.
So, making movies are long and tedious.
And it's a real gift when
you get to work with people
that can make you laugh.
- [Paul] Thank you.
- Yeah. What about you?
Was it your first time working together?
- It was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was, we'd been wanting to
work together for a long time
and we had developed
as producers together.
But I'd never acted with, or for, Paul
and I was really excited.
I'm such a huge fan.
The first time I saw
Bridesmaids, I was like...
Crying, "Who is this director?
How do I get to go to this party?"
- And will anything ever
top the bathroom scene?
I don't know.
- I don't know, I don't know.
- I don't think so.
- We need another break.
But I should also mention that
Paul has a book coming out
on November 15th.
It's called Cocktail Time.
Great advice, embarrassing
stories, and 125 classic
and original drinks.
So y'all be sure to look for it.
Now it's time to meet the person who made
all of this possible.
He's the author of the School
for Good and Evil Books
which have sold over 3 million copies
and he's the executive
producer for the movie.
Please welcome back to the show,
Soman Chainani!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] It's like, I was like,
it's that game musical chair.
It keeps moving.
So last time you were
here, we were talking
about this book and now
it's like a huge movie.
- It's crazy.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] It's so cool.
- It still feels like my mind exploded
and I haven't gotten all
the pieces back, you know.
So I feel a little bit jumbled.
- Yeah. Is it just
amazing to have something
in your head and heart thing,
you've had these characters' looks
and then see it come to life?
Because, I believe it wasn't a
lot of CGI, it was like real.
- Yeah, we did as much
practical as we could.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And I think what happens
is when you're a writer,
your canvas is usually
people's imaginations.
So you're used to never actually seeing
tangible results of your work.
You never see the world
actually built to life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So to actually see it feels like
you've won the lottery.
It just seems like an extra bonus.
- Yeah.
- And I just think the
entire experience of
especially this cast?
I mean, who gets this?
This is a once in a lifetime thing.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
It's an incredible chemistry.
So you even make a cameo in the movie.
So look, look at this everybody.
(Soman laughs)
- [Kelly] Yes! So cool!
I was like, was that for the one murder?
It was like, it was amazing.
It was like a teardrop.
So everyone here is a fan of your book.
So why do you think this
series resonates so?
- You know, when I started
writing it, I was 28.
A lot of doors were closing in my life.
I felt like professionally, personally,
romantically, creatively,
so much rejection.
And I think...
- [Kelly] Real break time. Wow.
(Kelly laughs)
- I just feel like people
have that moment in their life
where the universe is saying no to you.
And I felt like my path
was saying, "Change it up."
And I realized that
I no longer could be the
person people wanted me to be
and I had to commit to just being...
- That's exhausting.
- ...more on myself.
- Yeah.
- So, The School For
Good and Evil was like
a primal scream of my soul onto the page.
I was not in any way
thinking about success
or how it was gonna sell,
or what people were gonna think of it.
I just wanted to put
something that was all 100%
like me on there.
And the reason I think it's
resonated a lot with readers is
because we grew up being
told that if you're good,
then you will have a happy ending.
Everything's gonna open up for you.
You're gonna get the prince,
you're gonna get the princess.
All you have to do is be good.
But most of us spend our
entire life every day
we wake up...
- Growing that's a load of crap.
- Yeah. I don't feel good half the day.
Half the day I'm sort of cutting
in front of someone in the subway,
or like I'm accidentally like,
getting in the elevator
faster before someone else.
I'm pressing the button to close it.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like you're just constantly
doing little evil things.
- [Paul] That was you?
- [Kerry] Accidentally
closing the elevator?
- Little good things, little evil things.
And you're constantly going back and forth
between them and you
realize that we're never
ever gonna have the perfect happy ending.
We're not gonna have that ever after
because we're just trying
to be human every day.
We can't be good or pure evil.
We're, we're somewhere in between.
- It was a cool revelation in the film.
I'm not gonna say who did it, but one
of these people on the
couch had that moment
in the movie and I was
like, Oh, that's so true.
I was like, we're all capable.
- Yeah.
- Of both.
- So Charlize, I understand
that you have to to run
but you have something
that you wanted to say
to our audience, right?
- Yeah. Unfortunately we have
to go to the premier tonight.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- But it's just, I feel
like you, we can't waste
these outfits.
You guys made such an effort.
So you should join us.
- You should come.
(audience cheers)
- Everyone is the audience is headed
with the cast to the world premiere
of the "School for Good and Evil".
- [Charlize] It's awesome.
- Have so much fun.
You can see the "School for
Good and Evil" on Netflix.
Don't miss it. You're
gonna wanna watch it.